Leslie Sanchez a CBS News political
contributor and Republican strategist
joins us Leslie good morning good
morning let's start with a North Korean
summit the president back from Hanoi no
deal despite an unprecedented level of
engagement with a North Korean leader
but is there any progress for the
president in that meeting do you think I
think long term if you look at the long
lens of history there definitely will be
if you consider that no sitting
president has met with the North Korean
leader a lot of people go back and say
well there was Carter and Bill Clinton
did but they were they were you know
obviously past presidents so he's making
great strides there but you have two
bombastic leaders taking this
unprecedented step to come together and
this is not a fast rapid response it's
not gonna be having right away for
either country I don't think it behooves
the u.s. nor our relationship abroad but
I have to ask do you think there was a
real game plan going into this I love
that approach it it's hard to say what
the president was thinking but I think
strategically we have to give the
president props here in terms of
starting that conversation a lot of
people don't want to do that this is a
long ongoing effort we can see
historically that you've seen North
Korea both in the 90s and the 2000s
walked away from any of their D
nuclearization so you can't trust them
they have to build that credibility I
think that's what the president is doing
it may take five meetings it may take
four meetings but the fact we've had two
meetings in less than a year is really
significant at the same time we had
Michael Cohen testifying it was great
television but the true takeaways what
was the biggest takeaway from his
testimony I'm sure there's so much to
unpack there but the irony of the whole
thing is well it may not be about
Russian collusion it does open the door
wider to this idea of kind of backdoor
backroom deals that were happening with
the Trump organization that may or may
not have been legal and I think the fact
that a coat was like by the way these
are the individuals you should contact
this is their cell phone number I mean
Alan watch the burghers name what the
Berg's name could not have been said
more often no and it's like his office
is the third door on the right so
basically it's strategically exactly
where to find those breadcrumbs
Democrats are definitely gonna take
opportunity with that you saw the
Trump's particularly Eric and Don jr.
coming back and saying knowing he
perjured himself he was really looking
for a job they were really good parsing
different parts of his testimony but
there is a lot there that I do believe
the Democrats and some Republicans are
gonna be concerned is there a chance
that the Democrats get too caught up
though in some of these investigations
there was that concern of we can do more
than one thing but that concern has been
expressed it's definitely been expressed
the challenges that we're looking at a
political environment for 2020 what is
really going to motivate people to move
and get to the polls those many
fundamentally I think with a
center-right believe that Muller's
investigation is going to lay the
roadmap for the rest of the year if the
Democrats get in front of that with
their own investigations it looks like
partisan politics and not really kind of
truth and justice with respect to the
law Leslee quickly Jared Kushner
security clearance you've been through a
clearance process to work in the Bush
administration like this how is how
unusual is what happened with Jared it's
highly unusual for the reasons that
there are no short cut them short cuts
Anthony you can't just by presidential
privilege get that opportunity and the
difference when you get a nomination or
a political appointment or a commission
to an officer there is an accountability
that goes with that he is not held
accountable if he's working outside
those boundaries that's the concern not
only for the previous White House
Counsel there's certainly the chief of
staff but CIA CIA officials as well
we'll see what conservatives say a
little bit later a lot of yelling thank
you